your relationship with all things comedy
no just I mean we're a collective you
know you're oh you're part of the board
I heard that yeah but that's just I mean
the board that doesn't really means that
like if they're making decisions they
might who's in the board who's on the
board yeah re yeah bill bill burr you
Ari Shaffir Bert Kreischer how magical
how magical and maybe somebody else
that's the board yeah it's amazing he
has a paranoia that somehow he's gonna
get kicked off of all things comedy ends
of the board you were telling us to re
yeah why why would they kick you off I
don't know I just don't trust boards
there's something suspicious about it
I've seen movies where there's a board
in corporate but look here's my question
let's say they're like tomorrow would
you get the call and I go hey dude I
couldn't say it on them but we're
kicking you off what happens like wow
this is what let's do that phone call
now okay go ahead
hello hey Bobby it's Tom well what's up
to your grade on the podcast last night
dude thank you I had a great time okay
hey I wanted to tell you something I
couldn't say it's when we were doing the
podcast yeah but I was talking to you
guys on the board and you guys got it
you gotta go we're gonna we're gonna
take you off why I don't know we just
kind of we're thinking it over uh like
we kind of like other people all right
well can I just say though throw this
out there
yeah sure to you um I know what our
numbers are yeah and then this is what I
would say you want me real yeah it looks
be real I know what our numbers are okay
and I know the numbers on all the other
podcasts that you have yeah and we kill
it we kill them okay all right yeah we
do yeah we [ __ ] do all right all
right all right no no we [ __ ] do and
also numbers num number number two I got
a turn we do let me say this okay I meet
you then all right yeah Berndt you Rogan
el Rogan I'll bill you guys are my
friends
yeah I know it's not here's the thing
it's it's not personal
ah it's here's that here's why uh-huh we
just thought it would be fun to upset
you
all right all right all right well
that's I'm upset and I'm glad you're
having fun yeah um that's cool
we'll go on on our merry way yeah by the
way yeah we don't want you back okay all
right all right I feel like you'd be so
good at firing yeah yeah I'm actually
what you know what I could be good at in
a pretend capacity okay but not if you
really thought someone's livelihood was
auto but now we hang up right this is
what happens all right now so Bobby know
that one last thing yeah
eat a pile of [ __ ] all right all right
then we up the phone right yeah and it's
a year of it's gonna be weirdness
between me and you guys yeah for sure
nobody I know in this scenario these are
your real paranoia's cuz I think I feel
like a lot of his paranoids are so not
based on any type or even like a bit of
reality yeah it's always some absurd
[ __ ] that would never happen but he
believes it so strong
[Music]